.
>> THAT WOULD BE A BLAST.
>> YEAH.
YEAH.
VERY COOL.
ALL RIGHT, GAYLE?
>>> MY "TALK OF THE TABLE,"
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE AN EARLY
LOOK IN TONIGHT'S CBS NEWS
SPECIAL CELEBRATING QUEEN
ELIZABETH II AND HER HISTORIC
REIGN AND HISTORIC IS THE WORD.
IT'S CALLED "THE QUEEN CARRIES
ON."
WE SPOKE WITH SPECIAL GUESTS
INCLUDING FORMER PRESIDENT
BARACK OBAMA -- GOT TO TALK TO
HIM WHEN I WAS INTERVIEWING FOR
HIS BOOK AND SAID, CAN I ASK BUT
THE QUEEN?
HE GOES, OKAY.
OKAY.
THAT'S NOT WHAT THIS INTERVIEW'S
ABOUT, BUT OKAY.
AND THEN WE'RE GOING TO LOOK
BACK AT THE QUEEN'S LIFE
STARTING WITH HER CHILDHOOD.
♪
I THINK ABOUT HER AS A LITTLE
GIRL KNOWING SHE WAS GOING TO BE
QUEEN, WESLEY.
WHAT THAT MUST HAVE LIKE AS A
LITTLE GIRL AND HOW THAT WOULD
AFFECT YOU AS A CHILD.
>> I THINK SHE WAS VERY LUCKY
THAT SHE HAD LOVING PARENTS.
I THINK SHE HAD A LOVING HOME.
>> CASTLES AND COUNTRY HOMES AND
COMPANIONS.
>> I THINK ONE THING YOU'LL SEE
WITH THE ROYAL FAMILY IS DOGS
AND HORSES -- THEY LEARN TO RIDE
SHORTLY AFTER THEY LEARN TO
WALK.
>> THEY WOULD ALWAYS BE HER
COMFORT, AND SHE LEARNED WHAT IT
MEANT TO LEAD.
>> ELIZABETH WAS RAISED TO BE A
SERIOUS, STRONG, CAREFUL PERSON.
SHE HAD BEEN BROUGHT UP TO HAVE
A SENSE OF DUTY AND PATRIOTISM
AND LOYALTY TO HER COUNTRY.
♪
>> WHEN WAR BROKE OUT, THE
TEENAGE PRINCESS ROLLED UP HER
SLEEVES AND JOINED THE ARMED
FORCES.
>> PRINCESS LIELIZABETH HAS BEE
LEARNING TO DRIVE AND MAINTAIN
ALL TYPES OF MOTOR VEHICLES.
>> SHE LOVED IT.
SHE LOVED GETTING HER HANDS
GREASY AND DIRTY AND CHANGING
WHEELS AND MENDING CARS.
>> PRINCESS ELIZABETH IS NOW A
COMPETENT MECHANIC AND PROUD OF
THE FACT.
>> I KNOW.
THE QUEEN A MECHANIC, THINK
ABOUT THAT.
MORE THAN 27 MILLION PEOPLE
TUNED IN THAT DAY TO WATCH HER
CORONATION IN BRITAIN ALONE,
INCLUDING A 10-YEAR-OLD BOY FROM
LIVERPOOL WHO GREW UP TO BE
PRETTY FAMOUS HIMSELF.
WHO COULD THAT BE?
♪
AS ELIZABETH WAS GROWING INTO
HER ROYAL REIGN, PAUL McCARTNEY
PICKED UP A GUITAR AND HELD ON
TO HIS YOUTHFUL FASCINATION WITH
THE QUEEN.
>> WE THOUGHT SHE WAS A
GOOD-LOOKING WOMAN.
>> THE QUEEN?
>> YEAH.
>> LIKE A BABE GOOD-LOOKING?
>> JUST LIKE A BABE.
>> WHAT MADE HER A BABE, PAUL?
>> WE'RE PRETEEN BOYS IN
LIVERPOOL.
SHE LOOKED LIKE A FILM STAR TO
US.
>> DID YOU EVER DREAM OF MEETING
HER OR EVEN THINK THAT IT WOULD
BE A POSSIBILITY?
>> NO.
>> YEAH, OF COURSE NOT.
WE'RE JUST WORKING CLASS BOYS.
AND SHE'S THE QUEEN.
SO THERE'S AN OCEAN OR TWO
BETWEEN US.
SO I NEVER THOUGHT I WOULD UNTIL
WE BECAME THE BEATLES.
>> YEAH.
>> WE GOT RATHER FAMOUS.
>> YEAH, RATHER.
[ SCREAMS ]
>> THIS QUEEN WAS CLEARLY IN
TUNE WITH THESE TIMES.
[ CHEERS ]
HER MAJESTY UNDERSTOOD THESE
MUSICAL AMBASSADORS WERE THE
HOTTEST BRITISH EXPORT SINCE
SHAKESPEARE.
SHE WAS CRITICIZED FOR IT.
BUT IN 1965, THE QUEEN MADE THEM
THE FIRST ROCK STARS TO BE
HONORED AT BUCKINGHAM PALACE.
>> BIG SWANKY CAR PULLS THROUGH
THE PALACE GATES, AND YOU'RE
INSDE --
>> WHAT WERE YOU TOLD TO DO?
>> TO NOT SHAKE HER HAND, CALL
HER MA'AM, NOT YOUR MAJESTY.
YOU KNOW, IF SHE STOPS ON THE
LINE AND TALKS TO YOU, TALK TO
HER.
>> OTHERWISE --
>> OTHERWISE SHUT UP.
>> I LOVE HOW HE SAID "SHUT UP."
WE ALSO SPOKE WITH PAUL
McCARTNEY ABOUT THE QUEEN
REACHING THE MILESTONE OF
TURNING 95 YEARS OLD.
WE'RE SHARING THIS CLIP ONLY ON
"CBS THIS MORNING."
SO WE'RE VERY EXCITED TO TALK
ABOUT THE QUEEN BECAUSE OF ALL
THE PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM -- AND
THERE AREN'T A LOT, YOU ARE THE
ONLY ONE WHO HAS MET THE QUEEN
AND TALKED TO THE QUEEN.
WHAT DOES THIS MILESTONE MEAN TO
YOU?
>> I'M JUST PROUD THAT SHE CAN
KEEP GOING IN THAT REALLY
DIFFICULT JOB AND HANDLE IT SO
WELL.
>> YEAH.
>> SO TO REACH 95 AND STILL BE
HANDLING IT WITH SUCH EASE, I'M
JUST PROUD OF HER.
>> I REALLY LOVE TALKING TO HIM.
NUMBER ONE, I THANKED PAUL -- I
HAVE SUCH ADMIRATION AND RESPECT
THAT HE EVEN TOOK THE TIME TO
SPEAK TO US ABOUT THIS BECAUSE
HE -- HE DOESN'T DO MANY
INTERVIEWS.
WHEN HE WAS 10-YEARS-OLD IN HIS
CLASS HE HAD TO WRITE AN ESSAY
ABOUT THE QUEEN, THE CLASS DID,
AND PAUL WON.
PAUL WON THE WRITING CONTEST AT
10-YEARS-OLD.
GO FROM THAT -- HE WAS JUST
TALKING ABOUT WHAT A LOVELY
WOMAN SHE IS AND WHAT SHE
REPRESENTED.
AS YOU ARE WHEN YOU'RE T10.
YOU HAVE A FASCINATION WITH
ROYALTY.
TO GO FROM WRITING THAT ESSAY TO
THEN GOING TO MEET HER -- HE'S
BEEN TO THE PALACE SEVERAL TIMES
BECAUSE HE'S GOTTEN MANY AWARDS.
THEY DEFINITELY HAVE SOME KIND
OF CONNECTION.
>> YEAH.
I DO -- I LOVE THE FACT --
>> VERY RESPECTFUL.
>> I LOVE THAT THE QUEEN -- DID
SHE KNIGHT THEM?
KNIGHTED THEM -- THE BEATLES --
>> SIR PAUL.
AND PAUL'S WON A COUPLE OF
AWARDS JUST ON HIS OWN, JUST HIM
AND THE QUEEN.
HE'S VERY SPECIAL, THAT PAUL
McCARTNEY.
I LOVED ALL THE BEATLES.
YOU CAN WATCH "THE QUEEN CARRI